main kanal ist mittlerweile bekannt als
fundstelle für reaktionen auf den besten
content den youtube so zu bieten hat
nicht immer geht es aber um höchst
aufwendige mit oscar prämierten
schauspielern dekorierte
hollywoodproduktionen wie von einem
gewissen fernsehsender sondern manchmal
geht es auch um produktionen von anderen
youtube die in einem die höchsten
gefühle wecken man sich dabei einfach
nur noch denkt vor einem monat habe ich
mich schon mal einer meiner lieblings
youtube gewidmet nämlich wie black wing
mit dem video diese youtube ist zu weit
gegangen das ist bei euch selber
angekommen was mich gefreut hat und
jetzt darf ich euch verkünden dass die
zeit gekommen ist für einen zweiten teil
aber dich über berlin sondern über ihre
man könnte sagen zwillingsschwester ist
die rede ist von bonnie träsch man muss
an dieser stelle leider sagen und das
ist auch kein spaß dass bonnie strange
von derselben krankheit befallen ist die
auch rebecca winkt diese krankheit wenn
man im allgemeinen gespaltene youtube
persönlichkeit ganz konkret ein symptom
dieser krankheit ist unter anderem dass
man pakete vor der eigenen haustür ab
stellt und sich dann nicht mehr daran
gelangen kann
das muss gemacht hat und so tut als wäre
es ein unbekannter gewesen und zwar habe
ich dementsprechend beginnen wir die
heutige reise mit dem video unbekannter
legt mysteriöses paket vor meiner tür
[Musik]
da erkennt man schon die ersten symptome
es ist noch nicht ganz eindeutig aber es
waren sich schon an es klingelt an der
tür oder jedem normalen haushalt wäre
die reaktion
ich gebe nicht die muskeln was laberst
du ich bin schon vor drei wochen waren
die haustür gegangen ist dagegen die
tracks reaktion darauf dass die
türklingel läutet das war's es war alles
gut du musst noch nicht mit dem
schauspieler anfangen
ein ganz klassischen moment leute ein
unbekannter liegt ein mysteriöses paket
vor der tür
zuschauer von bodytrust rebecca wegen
wenn sich jetzt denken schon wieder aber
vor die unbekannte personen sich dann
von den boni trace haus tür aufmacht und
wieder ein paket von backlinks haustür
zu legen hat sie natürlich einmal ganz
kurz die kamera in die hand genommen um
bonnie träsch von außen zu finden wer
hat das gefühl wer die kamera ist für
diesen schrott aufgestellt ich dachte
dass garten unbekannter der mysteriöse
pakete ablegt so kann man nicht fragen
so das geht gleich das paket mal
zusammen
nicht nur jetzt geht s los leute jetzt
ist die gespaltene youtuber
persönlichkeit in vollem ausmaß bonnie
träsch hat sich das paket vor die eigene
haustür gelegt hatte dann eine kamera
aufgestellt und sich selbst zu filmen
beim rausgehen aber sie hat alles schon
wieder vergessen vor allem gegen es ist
sonntag da kommen doch gar keine paket
auslieferer wenig denn einfach
stillschweigend und paket vor die
haustür steht auf dem titel und bekannte
machen das übrigens einer der schon mal
eine kleine kritik an dicht boni träsch
und dann auch dich rebecca ring ich
finde es nicht gut dass ihr euren
unbekannten auch am sonntag arbeiten
auch unbekannte die mysteriöse pakete
ablegen sollten sonnenbergs zeit für
ihre unbekannte familie haben es ist
eines von bonnie treffen sich selbst da
sehen wir wieder wie gemein diese
krankheit ist leute sie führte sogar
dazu sich selbst zu beleidigen sie legt
die selbst ein paket vor die haustüren
beleidigt dann sich selbst dafür dass
das paket scheiße aussieht muss los
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nein ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass ich in diesem
jahr noch mal schauspielerische leistung
sehe die unter dem niveau von hilf mir
sind aber ich habe mich getäuscht
ohne dahin es ist ein weißer zettel
papier ich mir auch schaut mal hier ist
ein brief und das sind alles
ausgeschnittener einzelne buchstaben
immer hip hops ansieht dass sie sich die
mühe gemacht hat irgendwie buchstaben
aus zeitung auszuschneiden
das video an sich ist relativ bonnie
aber immerhin das hast du gut gemacht
okay wer fliegt jetzt hier glaube ich
dass wieder der unbekannte
wahrscheinlich 50 der unbekannte wieder
hat er danach die videoaufnahmen auf der
sd karte gegeben sagte ich bin es der
unbekannte hier ist eine videoaufnahme
für das video was haben wir das aber
leute spaß beiseite ich bleibe daran
punkt von ihnen unbekannte solchen
sonntags auch nicht fern witzig ist
übrigens auch ich habe also durch es
gibt es gibt scheinbar keine stelle die
vom unbekannten gefilmt ist wie bonnie
und ihr freund zusammen zu sehen sind
hält ja würden jetzt sagen dass ihr
freund ihr bekannt ist aber ehrlich sein
aber man musste einen bodycheck wird in
den kommentaren von ihrer community
supported zum beispiel lucy gar so aha
ich finde deinen kanal wird immer fällt
auch ein klassiker born ist kanal sind
die 24 stunden videos zum beispiel hier
24 stunden eingesperrt im gefängnis box
fort ich habe das video jetzt noch nicht
gesehen heute aber aber nach dem was ich
gesehen habe würde ich jetzt an der
stelle mal fünf euro oder auch wetten
dass bonnie träsch einfach weg so eine
halbe stunde in den box sport verbringen
[Musik]
aber ich habe natürlich noch mehr
material für euch in diesem video
weitere qualitative mp4 audiovisuelle
produktionen und zwar killer clown
drohungen in meinem amazon
adventskalender ganz kurz wie kommt man
auf die idee killer clown drohung in
meinem amazon adventskalender ich glaube
das ist auch ein symptom der gespaltenen
youtube persönlichkeit killer clowns
tauchen einfach auf in den videos ist
einfach so
sam
hört ihr das auch oder wenn es immer
wenn so was passiert in einem video ich
höre in solchen momenten wirklich
einfach meine gehirnzellen verschwinden
die frage ist so denkt man nicht darüber
nach wie also angenommen man glaubt
wirklich dass das echt ist denkt man
nicht über nachsuchen wie kommt das eher
ein
diese adventskalender wurde von amazon
gemacht verpackt und an sie verschickt
wo soll da ein killer klar irgendwas
reingepackt haben aber in die kinder
clowns jetzt bei amazon im lager oder
wie ich stelle mir so eine
stellenanzeige vor besuchen
lagerarbeiter für unseren amazon
standort in wiesbaden in hessen ganz
wichtig sie müssen zuverlässig sein
teamfähig sein und mindestens fünf jahre
berufserfahrung als killer kern haben
was ist das es ist normal dass einfach
nur clowns muss geduldig ist vollkommen
bescheuert dass sie das wäre das mit der
hand geschrieben cache seit diese
steuern carina der videokanal und die
firma verkauft
naja das ist von den clown zu lesen
steht noch was
ich weiß was hier abgeht das war mal
fragen jetzt liegt mir auch einiges was
hätte ich ja abgesprochen mit ihm oder
ok
man muss dazu sagen leute die spalten
der youtuber persönlichkeit scheint bei
boni träsch noch nicht so ausgeprägt zu
sein wie bei der lübecker ring aber das
geht schon in die gewisse richtung unser
kleiner ausflug nähert sich dem ende
leute bonnie an der stelle muss mir mal
sagen sei so gut und was deine
unbekannten sonntags nicht arbeiten und
ich biete eine wette an wenn du mir
nachweisen kannst du in einem der vier
20 stunden videos wirklich 420 stunden
im vauxhall fast ewig der fünf euro
sollten 420 den videos also doch recht
sein dann nehme ich meine entschuldigung
gerne zurück und fünf euro versprochen
ist kein job kriegst du von mir also ich
kann die selbst verhalten das heutige
heute tschechien für euch
vorgeschlagenes video ab und bis zum
nächsten mal